at the minimum level a value chain
consists of a supplier consists of
component suppliers of assemblies final
assembly manufacturing distributors
retailers wholesalers and ultimately
could be the end consumers and its whole
chain of network that are engaged in the
production of products and services
that's the basic value chain but now
increasingly value chain could include
the government because they could affect
and they could limit they could restrict
or they could support your your whole
delivery of products and services it
could include even NGOs because they are
also a stakeholder they could also
include logistics providers third-party
providers so I call that the complete
value chain or the ecosystem
so today very few companies are
completely vertically integrated meaning
that you make everything you make all
the components yourself you make all the
sub assemblies yourself and you
distribute yourself everyone depend on
somebody else
so you depend on your suppliers to
depend on your outlet you depend on your
distributor you depend on some third
party as a channel and if you're not
able to integrate that value chain well
synchronize then you could be very
efficient you could be very successful
but if your value chain partners cannot
fulfill their job your products may not
be successful or your services cannot
reach to the customers in your intended
fashion and expectation so we're all
interdependent and in order for a
company to be successful the whole value
chain has to be successful
most of the entrepreneurs in the
developing economies recognized that
they have huge constraints because the
government may not be supportive if
their roles are bad the infrastructures
are not dependable their suppliers are
not on time so they all recognize these
challenges well so what I would tell
these entrepreneurs is that you can
overcome this these barriers are not
insurmountable and you overcome it by
sometimes redefining what your roles are
creating the right information linkages
creating the right relationships sharing
sharing collaborating and those
challenges and constraints can be
overcoming once they overcome there
could be new business models and new
products and services
then you have not even thought of today
and so that's why I my simple advice is
challenges are great but they can be
overcome by the right innovations and
approaches innovations that could
require you to rethink the way you
deliver your products we think about the
incentives that you give the suppliers
so sometimes those barriers are because
the suppliers did not trust you or
because the suppliers do not have the
right information or because the
suppliers have their own constraints and
so helping them by collaborating with
them you overcome their barriers which
in turn unblock your own bottleneck so I
would say that by going out having the
right information share having the right
collaborations in place having the right
incentives in place can go a long way
when we went to Ghana when we went to
these developing economies oftentimes
the entrepreneurs because of the
experience and because of the
limitations that they have lived with
all their lives they only think of Spa
markets they only think of okay what can
I do to create this service so that I
can serve my village so that I can serve
my town my own region my own geography
but in fact if they understand the
complete value chain well they can
export they can serve other countries
they can expand what they're doing I'll
give you an example of the farmers that
I work with in Ghana
these are SIA butter garnish farmers the
women farmers so they roll share butter
which are nuts but it turns out that the
biggest value add is if they can also
learn how to process the nuts so that
they become ingredients for cosmetic
companies and that is a much higher
value add than just purely growing the
nuts using the nuts for food consumption
their own people consuming the nuts and
so this is really about a way of
understanding what role you play in the
big value chain and can you add more
value by doing more than what you're
doing today and by expanding the
geographic span that you can cover
such innovations and not just for the
sake of helping the developed economies
so that they would create values for
themselves and make people live better
there I would have to say that if you
are a multinational today large
corporations we also our own students
MPA students our own alumni we also
better understand those economies better
we also better learn how to leverage the
entrepreneurial power of those economies
matter we also need to leverage the
innovations that could come from
so-called bottom of the pyramid because
those innovations can also be
incorporated into these if even if
you're a big corporation because make
corporations often time have to expand
and you may one day go to those
economies those economies could be your
market this is like about 30 years ago
25 years ago people would think of China
as a developing economy and you would
only use China as a place where you can
have cheap labor as a source to build
your products to manufacture your
products but today China is no longer a
developing economy even though pockets
of China are still developing but China
is a market China is a big market China
is a source of innovation same thing
could happen in different parts of
Africa in different parts of South Asia
in different parts of South America so I
would say that while we go out there
with the intent to help the
entrepreneurs in the region but I think
regardless of whether you are looking at
the interest of big corporations in
developed economies this kind of value
chain innovations are crucial for the
overall economic development of everyone